[Music]
man it is a great day here we've had uh
tremendous sandwiches i ate five
sandwiches i saw that and now we have
the best
our own cooking confidence coach nanny
bubbe back in studio thanks to chapman
automotive the sponsors of the segment
today and today we're going to learn how
to make a perfect summer dessert perfect
i had my meal i had the five sandwich
and now you have now i've got a grilled
peaches with greek yogurt and honey
right there you go and it's easy which i
don't really push easy but this just so
happens that it is so that's nice
i just want to tell jc i do that jump
every single day so yeah i'm telling you
like he thought he thought it was a big
deal i do it every day no
so we've got these beautiful summer
peaches do you love stone fruit and you
know we've got peaches nectarines plums
they are just they ooze summer right get
them fresh they're amazing and these are
fresh sent to us and all these for the
crew by melissa's produce so yeah
everybody for that so the first thing
we're going to do is take a freshly
washed peach and we are going to slice
it
just long-wise around that pit and then
you're going to take it and you're going
to twist
out comes the pit on one side
and then you're going to take a
grapefruit spoon and this is a little
bit harder if it's not too on this one
oh my god it knows we're on tv it came
right out so that's super duper then
we're going to take a little bit of
orange flavored olive oil from my
favorite olive oil company i just love
this orange flavored what's the name of
it uh temecula olive oil company
you can get it online which is where i
get it and we're just brushing these
peaches
with
the orange can you smell it oh my gosh
orange flavored olive oil just a nice
little glazed brush like this and then
we're going to take it and stick them on
this grill which hopefully is nice and
hot it's either been too hot or not on
one of these i know it's been one of
each and then we want to spray it
because the spraying of this helps it be
a little more brown because you really
want those grill marks so we'll spray
like that over spray let's see if we can
hear a sizzle so olive oil spray well
there is a small sizzle there we go
imagine if you will a large city a large
sizzle and what i do is put a nice heavy
it is because avocado oil can heat up
above 375 and not be toxic so when
you're grilling like that always use
avocado oil so i always put a heavy pot
on this to keep it grilling so that we
have beautiful grill marks just like
this so look at how beautiful that is
and these have caramelized which is
really awesome so this will sit on the
grill and we will let them grill up and
caramelize for about five to seven
minutes depending on how hot your grill
actually is and how hot should it be
about 400 degrees i think this got to
600 degrees which is why it shut itself
off but anyway we're moving on so now so
easy you see all this beautiful
glistening in here and we're just going
to take the yogurt and just right dollop
look at that
beautiful right and the juices just
drizzle out i love this idea this does
seem
very simple someone like me could pull
this off i think somebody like anybody
could but i think you're not giving
yourself enough credit because you're my
friend yeah no i love you and i think
that cooking is intuitive and
instinctual and i think you have good
intuition and good instincts so you will
be able to do it as will anybody at home
i like that okay and now we're going to
take
homemade uh granola or store bought and
just sprinkle it on top
now i forgot the french sea salt because
you know i'm a big fan of french sea
salt on anything and i think a little
bit of sweet and savory is delicious you
just sprinkle if you had some you just
sprinkle yeah yeah i would i'd finish it
with the french sea salt and then here
is
mint
and
look at that beautiful the presentation
is beautiful yeah but it gets better but
i almost forgot this don't and then off
you know like on to the plate a little
bit give it some color some beauty
i love that and there you go yeah
and you're done and ready to rock and
roll there do you like that i love this
that's a great great idea and on on
behalf of melissa's produce who sent
these really truly they over sent me
peaches just for the crew today nothing
like fresh peaches everybody's like
cheering yeah are they all right there
you go so marla thank you so much as
always
do you know how to say spread love like
better can you say it with me on the
count of three one two three spread love
like butter
check out nanny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment and we have more las vegas now
right after this
you